it is easier to make 300 a month than it
is to cut 300 a month out of the average
citizen's budget suzy orman dave ramsey
they're always like don't spend money
don't spend money don't go get the five
dollar coffee guess what you are more
likely to find a path to creating 300
more of income per month than most
people are in cutting 300 monthly
expenses i think most people think it's
easier to cut something out than find a
way to make more money yeah they're
wrong let's just say that your monthly
expenses are twelve hundred dollars and
say to somebody cut 25
of your monthly expenses twenty-five
percent yeah that change that changes
your life you gotta do work it doesn't
just fall out of the sky contrary to the
socialist belief